je ne vois pas ce qu'est en train de
faire la droite on que déroulé le tapis
de la délégitimation de du suffrage
universel et des élections qui ont eu
lieu et donc de laisser le tapis rouge
déployé pour marine le pen on voit bien
qu'ils n'ont pas réglé leur problème de
leadership qui n'ont pas de
contre-propositions mais ils sont dans
une violence et une morgue de françois
fillon excessive qui met vous le dit ou
pas qu'ils ont plus qu'ils sont dans un
état d'esprit putschistes matin jugé
président de prononcer une petite phrase
qui fera encore le buzz toute la journée
ils ont eu une attitude
en tous les cas au moment de 2,2 du
débat sur le mariage homosexuel qui
était réellement aux lisières de du
respect de la démocratie et de la
démocratie parlementaire dans un moment
où parce qu'il ya ces tensions sociales
et ses difficultés il faut au contraire
légitime et tout ce que ce sont nos
institutions on a entendu attaquer les
juges monsieur guaino dire que le
parlement n'avait pas à légiférer
n'était pas légitime cautionner des
violences et des propos violents mais
pas seulement
même des violences physiques dans la rue
aujourd'hui on appelle à manifester
comme ça globalement sans aucune
perspective hier sans trop